[Music]
we just landed in we pulled over so keep
you can pull the camera out you're like
oh we're about to meet my parents
we should blog that we should and we are
I hope you guys are enjoying this
[Music]
oh my god he's tall
oh I know you bought a house crazy
oh nice that they start moving ready
nobody moved it all they already moved
in that's fast Wow you just sign the
papers like to eat burritos only four
minutes walk oh really wow that's
awesome it's so close
the water spot back to the carry is
frightening clothes not even though just
walk in huh I got you a policy for your
crank you already left me cuz that's
like your favorite show too right
everybody loves room so we're in Dallas
and it's gonna be a very very short trip
we're only here for three days
we came because we'll find out tomorrow
that's the reason why we came Oh coming
at a bad time I am cleaning baby's poop
in Peoria better don't pass though I
know this is my this is my dream home
yeah like like a shirt thanks dude
congratulations man it's a talented
creator shirt mm is not an album dude
these are dope yeah I like those like
hipster oh yeah adds a lot to the room
it makes it feel really uh it's very
updated here
yeah oh you got a backyard
that's true it's so used to living in LA
now I'm like bagged your honor Oh Britta
have a dog lucky
[Music]
why you so tired we're waking up at 5:00
a.m. a lot for different reasons I'm
just exhausted
yay I've been likes work hard play hard
so yesterday I film JK news and like I
was so tired that I was just like I just
made a fool of myself like every other
video I was like really not all there
blue badly about black that's not the
same way too about your tart and I
didn't get any sleep when I have vlog or
when I do stuff on camera I'm just
lightly blablabla anyway it's my
family's new shop
it's a after school program where kids
learn how to code they bought into the
franchise who the franchise so their
franchisees which means they own this
one in particular but it's like a team
if you live in the u.s. I'm pretty sure
you see utilities pop up everywhere just
walk in
[Music]
we have one you want oh yeah you have
one that's right you're wearing every
day of school hmm
is your already a ninja let me see that
again
all right so Mama's gonna show you
something special
[Music]
okay if we're surrounded by people that
have businesses and stuff I'm gonna have
a business you won't have a business no
we shouldn't have a business we're like
the only losers without a business like
literally all of our friends and family
absolute misses I want to have a
restaurant but I know that's a lot of
work in man-hours so I think that's like
a future dream I still need to work with
my movie dream first before I do my
restaurant drinks I'm looking to do
though me I don't know he's I had my
movie dream dreams now you have a I want
to open a store dream yeah but not like
anything in particular
I don't know right now I'm too tired to
talk about this true I'm like half awake
half asleep what is that these parts and
who is but there is some coding ears
like so YouTube has coding the color
coded on the paper and then you put
their robot in here it will follow the
color oh it's you a program where to go
[Music]
it just occurred to me that this place
is the same place that we came to when
we went to that one video stored in that
one Christmas trip so we are inside a
relic this place used to be a video
rental spot last year during Christmas
we came to location scout to see if this
place is gonna be a good spot for a code
ninjas fast forward 9 min a year now it
looks like this
all right finally home united home sweet
home for me because I didn't grow up in
this out of her home and my dad has made
this world-famous abalone world world
famous in the whole world
wake I am now breathing all like video
is just me exhausted it was the darkest
circle ever I don't blame ya yeah JT
knew so yeah like trick-or-treating
yeah then same night ahead study for
Jake can use the next day which I said
no I can't do this instead I'm gonna go
to sleep right now which was like 11:30
or midnight and I woke up the next
morning at 5 a.m. so I could study 28
articles and then I went to JK me
yesterday like a full 14 hour day
[Music]
but it was fun I don't know how I did it
but like I said I made a fool of myself
so all the videos where I'm wearing a
yellow sweater that was yesterday's ami
mode yeah those are the best videos that
when everyone gets delirious and
tiredness see those are the fun it's
like whenever we do the full day's and
we are
like the second session which is from 4
p.m. to 8 p.m. but usually it's until
like 9 p.m. because if you end up going
late that's when we're all very
delirious and then we'll just start
having fun because we're just so tired
we're like we don't even know what's
happening anymore but that was my whole
thing yesterday and then today this
morning we wake up at 5 a.m. because our
flight was at 8 a.m.
trying to sleep on the plane a little
bit just been trying so hard to like
wake up enjoy your family girls I think
you don't see them often so I'm like oh
my god
I guess no I'm really looking forward to
eating this stuff this is something I'm
always looking forward to we're about to
eat like Chinese royalty abalone abalone
abalone I always forget I don't know
comment down below you can eat that
Bologna or abalone yes so your fungus
[Music]
that your abuelo and then can do I like
her fungus so we're about to eat like
Chinese world's here we got my dad's
world-famous abalone and we got my mom's
world-famous papaya soup
Isaac doesn't want any and Isaac is
missing up he doesn't want any it's too
tough yeah it's like a disc yeah yes
cooking we're going to Hong Kong in
December so yeah you better get used to
some Chinese royalty food right here
Hey
[Laughter]
like a Chinese steak right here but it's
pretty much just like
you outdid yourself again Papa you I am
trying to soup yet mom this beautiful
soup right here that's sweet
very aromatic
[Music]